there are some americans in donbass who
are reporting on the war there and i
read their reports actually they're
pretty interesting because they show you
the cruelty of what's going on but never
mentioned in the west never that's
what's so strange about this this this
is a modern world that we're living in
yet this information is not coming out
to the mass of the people and on the
contrary the united states has closed
down
all the all the prop all the rt all the
all the information centers that are
possible alternative news getting to the
american people they've seriously made
an effort and the bbc
the english
and france i was shocked when france
closed rt down because rt is actually
pretty good they yes they may you could
call there are distortions but you know
as well as i do because you hear you
speak
that rt has done a very
brave job of putting correspondence into
the field in very dangerous positions
and they've gotten great footage
of some of the violence that's going on
well given the wall of propaganda in the
west
i also see the wall of propaganda in
russia the wall of propaganda in china
the wall of propaganda in india
what do we do with these walls of
propaganda yeah let's talk about russia
because i you and you would know more
about it but my last experience there
newspapers it was more interesting
there's
put it this way when i went to venezuela
the united states was saying
back then that chavez controlled the
press i get to venezuela and there's
nothing but criticism of chavez in the
press it was owned by the the oligarchs
of venezuela and who hated him so it was
across the board that's why chavez
opened the uh
the state television
spent more money on and advertised his
point of view through state television
but this in russia uh there is uh what i
saw was criticism i met with a publisher
who got the nobel prize of that famous
newspaper
and his point of view at that time when
i spoke to him a few years ago was
we're operating there is criticism of
him but you know we you can't call for
the overthrow of the government
nor in venezuela nor in the united
states for that matter if you call for
the overthrow of
the government of the united states
you're going to be in deep trouble well
all right so to push back on that it's
interesting it's so interesting because
we mentioned elon musk and there's a way
that people sound when they speak freely
when i speak to i have family in ukraine
i have family in russia when i speak to
people in russia let's put my family
aside when i speak to people in russia
i think
there's fear
i think
they don't
um sometimes when you call for the
overthrow of government that's important
not because you necessarily believe for
the overthrow of the government but you
just need to test
test the power centers and make sure
they're uh responsive to the people and
i feel like there's a mix of fear and
apathy
that
it has a different texture than it does
in the united states
that worries me because i
i
would like to see the flourishing of a
people in all places
as i said my impression was that there's
far more freedom in the press than was
it was pictured by the west and and that
means different points of view because
the russians are always arguing with
themselves i've never seen a country
that's so contentious there's more
there's more
intellectuals in moscow and the cities
than than you can believe and and you
know the russian people there
they've been fighting government for
years back from the 1870s zara's times
they're always plotting against the
government and the intelligence has
known through history as being
contentious and anti-government in many
ways and uh we see the same thing
educated people turning against russia i
don't appreciate those people because i
think they're very spoiled and they
don't understand some of the stuff
that's going on in the west but we have
a lot of russians in in them in europe
and america
that attack russia and sometimes don't
understand that they are under pressure
from the united states and they don't
understand the size of the pressure
and it that's why putin connects with
the people because he
he represents
the common more the common man
who's who's saying to you your interests
are threatened russia is threatened we
are representing only the interests of
russia not we're not an empire we're not
going to expand
he has no empire intentions all the west
pains in his empire
i i see no evidence of it uh why didn't
he do something in all these years
nothing he did nothing except defend the
country in georgia and in chechnya so
the imperialist imperative is coming
more from the west
it's the imperialist agenda going back
to uh i'm sorry where we left our
discussion off i mean i was going to go
on with america not only being censored
as closed down now
closed down and you say it's not it's
not fear well it is fear
i am scared because if you get your
facebook page suspended or your youtube
your twitter account thrown off a lot of
good people are getting there
thrown off
you can't say you can't speak out it
affects your business it goes back to
the 1950s when my my father's world when
you could not express any sympathy for a
soviet union without endangering your
job without basically being not trusted
you had to be part of the program to get
along to go along
same thing when uk united kingdom i mean
for all their talk this boris johnson is
an idiot
but all their talk about do you remember
their policies with the ira in ireland
when ireland was threatening them they
cut off the ira completely jerry adams
who was a a wonderful guy i met him
was not allowed to even be heard in
britain during certain years in france
all constantly through the algerian war
the algerians were not allowed to be
heard the algerian war for independence
divided france greatly
you could not even show paths of glory
world war one film uh in france for i
don't know 20 years after it came out uh
censorship is a way of life when
democracies also feel threatened they're
much more fragile than they pretend to
be a healthy democracy would take all
the criticism in the world and shrug it
off and say okay that's what's good
about our country well i'd like to see
that in america it used there are times
it's been like that but it's it's so
scary now so it is scary that's that's
what i was trying to say it's not
unscary to me
in china i would say to you yes it's
much scarier to me because
there is
the internet wall that they cut off and
i got into problems in china too because
i said something in in years ago about
you have to discover your own history
you have to be honest about mao you have
to be you have to go back and
let's make a movie about mao that upset
them you know and show his negatives
so china has been much more sensitive
than russia about criticism much more
and it is a source of problems but on
the other hand china has
a lot of grievances a lot going back to
the 19th century and the british
imperialism of that era and american
imperialism
you